Every spring, millions celebrate Easter
thinking that it honors the resurrection
of Jesus Christ. They hold Easter
services, sunrise gatherings, pancake
breakfasts on Easter morning, all
believing that it reverences the day
that Jesus rose from the grave. But what
if I was to tell you that the real roots
of Easter had nothing to do with Jesus?
But they had everything to do with
fertility rights, blood sacrifice, and
the son's rebirth. You're watching
Candid Truth, and this is the full
Easter
expose. Those golden round pancakes that
we have on Easter morning. They're not
just breakfast food. They are cooked in
the image of the sun, served usually at
sunrise, and in ancient rights,
fertility rights, that is. They used to
bake cakes on Easter morning to the
goddess of the dawn following
ritualistic orgies to honor the return
of the sun. What we now see as harmless
brunch actually echoes the ancient pagan
fertility cults of its time. Occult
ceremonies of sun worship in disguise.
Behind today's Easter actually lies with
the goddess Oester or Ishtar spelled E O
S T R E, the fertility goddess of
Babylon. Her worship involved orgy,
eggs, and death. Oester is also known as
the goddess of the dawn who brings
fertility and light after winter's
darkness. Her symbols included the hair
and the egg, both signs of new life.
Ancient Germanic peoples honored her at
the time of the spring equinox with
sunrise rights and fertility rituals.
Now, many people ask about Easter. Is it
found in the Bible? Well, in our modern
day Bible through translation, it
actually does show up once. That is in
Acts 12:4. However, we need to
understand something very crucial about
this. It's a passage shows that Herod,
who had just killed James, was waiting
until Passover for the Jews and Easter
for the pagans was over in order to kill
Peter, whom he had already arrested. He
was keeping this pagan festival. That's
why he was referencing it and honoring
it and waited until it was over in order
to do so. here. We should not get it
mixed up with ever being something God
intended or Christian God's people
doing. The egg is not just some cute
decoration. It has real meaning,
symbolism, and roots in this Easter
thing. You see, cuz in mystery
religions, it represents the cosmic egg.
Its connections are with the cosmic egg
of the occult gnostic doctrines. This
means that it is a pagan symbol of the
universe, birth and cycle of death and
renewal. Druid priests actually carried
eggs as a symbol of their cult and as
sacred objects. For the Egyptians, we
have Hatheror. She was called the cosmic
mother who emerged from the egg of Rah.
Babylonian myths claim that Samuris fell
from the heavens in an egg and became
the queen of heaven. However, we see in
Jeremiah
7:8, it says specifically not to worship
the queen of heaven. She is mentioned by
name. It says, "The children gather wood
and the fathers kindle the fire and the
women knead their dough to make cakes to
the queen of heaven that they provoke me
to anger." That's the Lord stating this.
We see that these aren't myths. They
never were myths. They are Luciferian
religion masquerading as tradition which
have always existed throughout time. In
these springtime fertility rights,
especially for the Druids and the
Canaanites, they would bring virgins at
dawn to the temple to be impregnated by
the priests at sunrise in these orgy
rituals. The Ashira poles of which the
Bible speaks about specifically would be
used and we know them today as mapoles.
However, they were orgy poles of which
the ribbons directed you to your next
sexual partners one after another. Why?
Because approximately 9 months later
around December 24th to 25th, these
babies that were conceived and born from
Easter would be sacrificed that next sun
festival just in time to create
consistent sources of human sacrifice.
You see, their blood was used to dye the
eggs. All Easter eggs were originally
red for the blood of these infants. This
is actually where the ritual of dying
eggs comes from. They were not just
tokens. They were symbolic memorials of
the children that had come before their
sacrifice of their life in order to
provide fertility to the soil and to the
town's populace to ensure the
flourishing of that town or that nation.
They believe that these were all
necessary acts for bountiful harvests so
that they could have all of the favor of
the gods for all of the earth and
mankind. It's not exactly a cute
tradition, is it? Instead, it's a
chilling remembrance of the blood
sacrifices to Baal and Ishtar. Now, the
Easter Bunny, many of us have always
asked, why the Easter Bunny? Well,
unfortunately, it's not innocent either.
Legend had it that a Wester's lover who
had died in her grief, she had caused a
hair to be transformed into him and made
it lay these eggs at this time of year
every Easter only once a year. This is
the actual origin of bunnies laying
eggs. A tale of resurrection of Christ?
No, not of Christ, but of pagan gods.
And the Easter that goes back to the
Babylonian tales of Tamuz. This was
Ishtar's son. Her son lover who was
killed by a wild boar. Eating a ham on
Easter is in remembrance of his death
almost in a vengeful festival of eating
the boar's flesh. We see this in Ezekiel
8:14 where God shows Ezekiel a vision of
women weeping for tamuz at the temple
and he calls it an abomination. Yet
today, the world still seems to keep
weeping for Tamuz in this way and
celebrates pagan gods in disguise. All
of this ties into what the occults call
the golden age. It's a vision that they
have been pursuing ever since their
plans were foiled and men were all
scattered at the Tower of Babel. It
represents a supposed futuristic utopia
where humanity is enlightened, having
cast off all biblical Christianity and
teachings in favor of ancient paths of
goddess worship, sun reverence, and the
pursuit of hidden or forbidden
knowledge. The egg in this system
becomes a symbol of that rebirth. not a
rebirth of life in Christ, but into the
counterfeit system of the Antichrist.
And holidays aren't just innocent
traditions. They are social engineering,
a way to keep the masses aligned with
pagan thought while believing that they
are honoring God. As all holidays are
meant to deceptively do. You see, the
world isn't moving away from religion.
It's actually being drawn into the one
world cult through culture, through
media, through the merging of all gods
into one deceptive system. As every
other religion, cult, and secret society
and order, Jesuits, Freemasons, and
beyond, we have historically seen that
they have played their role into luring
humanity into this spiritual deception
from the very beginning. So, you might
ask yourself this Easter, what does the
Bible say about Easter? I've mentioned
that in and of itself, it only mentions
it once. However, we can actually get
more understanding and knowledge from
what it commands elsewhere. Such as in
Jeremiah 10:2 where it says, "Learn not
the way of the heathen." In 2
Corinthians 6:15, "What concord hath
Christ with a lil or ba?" and Ezekiel
8:14-15 which says, "And he brought me
to the door of the gate of the Lord's
house, and behold, there sat women
weeping for tamuz." Then he said unto
me, "Hast thou seen this, oh son of man?
God calls us to be separate, apart, and
holy, not partakers of the work and the
rituals of the world's spiritual
harlotry. If the root is unclean, so is
its fruits." God is repeating and
warning us not to follow the customs and
traditions and religious practices of
the surrounding nations who worship
false gods. Unfortunately, we can also
see that Jesus never mentioned at all us
keeping the day of his resurrection or
death. He never told us to make it a
holiday. Yet with the Catholics, it is
called a movable feast which always is
on the spring equinox. That's why the
dates vary. meaning it never stays on
the same date. Wouldn't you know that
something is important to God because he
can always tell you it is always on this
day. Always. And yet it's not. No, it
follows the cycles of the equinox just
like the pagans followed the movements
of the sun and the moon. Did you catch
that? It is not following scripture but
the cycles and movements of the sun and
moon just like pagans reflects the
sunbased ritual system that God warned
his people to avoid. Pagan origins and
holidays cannot simply be rebranded to
be for Jesus or God and claim to honor
him. As scripture reminds us, God is not
pleased when his people adopt the
customs of false worship. regardless of
the intention behind them. As many say
that was not my intention, I meant to
keep it for Christ. But one cannot
repurpose intention either behind an
action or a ritual. It is what it is. So
this is what we come to down the rabbit
hole. This is the truth about Easter. I
hope you guys like that. If you want to
know more about the cosmic egg, please
go look at our episode on that. And if
you want to know more about the other
holidays, please go visit our channel
where we have more indepth deep dives of
the holidays. Part one and part two.
Three is coming up. Thank you so much
for your support. We love you guys.
Bye-bye. Candid truth.
[Music]